hey this is presh talwalkar
construct a square and shade its
interior in blue
then construct four semi-circles as
shown
the diameter of each semicircle spans
the center of the square to a corner of
the square
and each of the four arcs of the four
semi-circles are oriented
counter-clockwise from their diameters
shade the interior of each of these
semi-circles in white
then shade the region that's exterior to
the square but interior to the
semi-circles in blue
the question is if the side of the
square has a length equal to 4
what is the area of the region shaded in
blue
i thank the puzzle creator at cshare41
and i saw it via at wait but y
all on twitter
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
there are many ways to solve the problem
but i will illustrate one method
construct four line segments
each line segment connects the center of
the square to a midpoint of the square
the region between this line segment
and the circular arc of the semicircle
is a circular segment and it's exactly
equal to the circular segment that's
outside of the square
in other words we can move each of these
circular segments outside of the square
to the region that's inside the square
from here we've just shifted the blue
area so if we solve for the blue area
that remains we'll get the original
answer
we have now created four isosceles right
triangles
so we just need to figure out the sum of
the areas of these four triangles
this is a straightforward task
notice that we have divided the square
into eight congruent right triangles and
four of them are shaded in blue
therefore the area shaded in blue is
exactly half of the square's area
the square's area is equal to four times
four which is equal to sixteen and if we
take that divided by two we get that the
blue area is equal to eight
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you